you might look funny doing this but this
is how it works you go to the park and
then you walk really slow and then
without warning you sprint like a tiger
about to eat you for 20 maybe 30 seconds
and then you would lay on your back in
the park and do deep breathing exercises
where your exhale is twice as long as
your inhale for probably two 2 and half
minutes and you're going to do it one
more time land your back until your
heart rate's normal and then you're done
all we're telling the body is
cuz remember these are dumb cells in
your operating system they don't know
what's going on they can't see time they
can't see tigers they just know there
must have been a tiger and here's the
trick but I got
away right okay and now I'm peaceful and
I'm safe now I'm safe signal that causes
the body to allocate nutrients to muscle
and to cardiovascular and mitochondria
that's the trick